today we're going to continue our
discussion of consumer choice and we're
going to talk now about what happens
when we take that unconstrained choice
we talked about on Monday and impose
budget constraints we'll talk about what
budget constraints are will then come to
talking about how consumers may
constrain choices and then we'll end
with an example of food stamps so let's
talk start by talking about budget
constraints and we'll start by talking
about their construction the
construction of budget constraints
so basically um last time we talked
about the fundamental axiom of consumer
choice that more is better so what
stopped people from just binging on
everything it's their budget constraint
it's their limited resources now for
most of this course we're gonna make a
simplifying assumption that your budget
that is what you spend equals your
income that is what you earn okay that
is there won't be any savings or
borrowing okay now that is a simplifying
assumption and indeed we'll spend a
couple lectures to the end of semester
talking about what happens when people
can save or borrow that said this is not
a terrible description of most Americans
the median American household has four
hundred dollars in the bank so this is
not kind of a terrible description of
the way most people live their lives in
America which is what they earn each
week is what they spend each week so
that's what we'll do it also might not
be sort of a terrible description of
your life I presume in college you're
not doing a lot of savings you maybe do
a little borrowing but not a lot of
savings are borrowing so we're gonna do
is we're gonna assume that's true for
you as well we're gonna assume your
parents have given you some amount of
money to spend we'll call it why your
income why is the amount of money your
parents are giving you to spend for save
the semester or the month and once again
let's say all you spend your money on is
pizza and cookies okay that's all you
want to spend your money on we write the
budget constraint as saying that your
resources your income why can
spent on either pizza or cookies and the
constraint is that you could spend it
that that a budget has to be divided
between Pizza where there's the price
per slice of pizza times the number of
slices of pizza or cookies we have the
price per cookie times the number of
cookies so P sub P is the price per
slice of pizza P sub C is the price per
cookie P's then it repeats us and sees
the number of cookies that's your budget
constraint you can essentially devote
your income to some combination of pizza
and cookies and but you have to consider
how much they actually cost in doing
that I find this easy to see graphically
so let's turn to figure 3 1 figure 3 1
shows a budget constraint so how's the
budget constraint look well the x-axis
is your income divided by the price of
cookies that is if you decide to devote
all your income to cookies that how many
cookies you can you have Y over PC if
your income is 100 and cookies are 10
bucks yeah that means you're going to
miss on your cookies then then you can
only have 10 cookies etc likewise the
y-intercept is the income divided by the
price of pizza that's how many pieces
you can have the budget constraint
represents the budget constraint the
slope of the budget constraint is the
price ratio the negative of the price
ratio because it's a downward sloping
line PC over P P that is on every extra
cookie that you by holding your income
constant lowers the amount of pizza you
can have by P sub P ok so let's consider
an example suppose that Y is 96 dollars
that the price of pizza is expensive
pizza place is $12 and the price of a
cookie is $6 ok $12 for pizza this is
like downtown San Francisco or New York
$96
come $12 for a slice of pizza $6 for a
cookie okay I'm sorry why it's going to
make y72 my bed it's why 72 your income
is $72 okay and you could spend it on
pizza and cookies and those two prices
now what that means is if you wanted
just pizza you get six pizzas if you
want to just cookies you can get twelve
cookies and generally the rate of the
rate at which you can trade off pizza
for cookies is minus a half okay
that is every additional cookie would
require giving up half a slice of pizza
okay every additional cookie Christ give
me have a slice of pizza that's why the
slope would be negative 1/2 okay so
basically we're gonna call the slope of
the budget constraint the slope we're
gonna call the marginal rate of
transformation the MRT last time with
EMRs the margin rate of substitution now
we're gonna have MRT the margin rate of
transformation which is equal to minus
PC over P P or the slope of the budget
constraint okay that is the marginal
rate of transformation now this class is
not alchemy we are not literally
transforming pizza into cookies that
would be kind of cool but we're not
doing that that's somewhere else at MIT
okay but if effectively doing the same
thing what we're doing is given Italy a
fixed amount of money and given that
we're going to spend it all the more you
spend on pizza the less you spend on
cookies so you're effectively
transforming pizza into cookies and vice
versa because you're gonna spend all
your money you guys been on something so
the more you spend on one the less you
get of another go through the budget
string we are effectively transforming
one good to the other worth by having
more of one we're getting less of the
other so that's this said to which we
call it the marginal rate of
transportation and you have
transformation so basically this comes
back to the key concept we talked about
in the very first lecture opportunity
cost the opportunity cost
of a slice of pizza is two cookies
remember opportunity costs is that is
the value of the next best alternative
okay the opportunity cost is value the
next best alternative well here you only
have two alternatives pizza and cookies
so the opportunity cost of a slice of
pizzas to cookies and that's the sense
of what you're transforming pizza into
cookies or cookies into pizza okay
now this seems kind of abstract but
let's actually think of an organization
which is taking this principle the heart
to develop the best method of weight
loss in America which is Weight Watchers
okay Weight Watchers now it turns out
that dieting is super hard and basically
doesn't work okay there's a large
literature which says that people go on
diets all the time then they stop them
and they gain the weight back
okay dieting is incredibly hard to base
that doesn't work okay but a much more
successful approach has been established
by Weight Watchers it's not the only
approach but it's been proven and much
more successful okay
and essentially what does Weight
Watchers do they set up a budget
constraint and ask you to follow it so
for example they essentially assign
point values to every good you might
consume you go on the website and
everything in the world you might want
to eat has a point value they then asked
well what weight do you are you today
what's your age and gender that stuff
matters for weight loss and what weight
do you want to achieve and they say if
you want to achieve a weight loss of X
over Y days then you've got to limit
yourself to Z points okay
so essentially your goal is to lose
weight so we're going to view the budget
constraint we're not gonna tell you what
to eat that's why it's better than
dieting because once again Adam Smith
was right people like to have choices
they like to let choice drive things but
we are going to tell you total budget so
for example weight vegetables are like
zero points Snickers bars are like six
points etc they have various point
systems okay so for example suppose your
budgets 30 points which would be pretty
typical okay
suppose you go to McDonald's for lunch
and you get a number one the number one
in McDonald's is a Big Mac which has 14
points fries which have ten points and a
coke which has six points that's thirty
points and it's only lunch okay you've
blown your whole budget for the day on
lunch now you could just get depressed
and say screw it I'll just be fat but
clearly looking around the room you guys
have not made that choice or you could
look at the budget constraint say well
what else can I get what turns out you
can get a ten-piece nugget which is
twelve points apple slices which is one
point in a diet coke which is zero
points for only 13 points
now if 13 points have plenty of room for
dinner now to be honest anyone who tells
you that second lunch is goes that first
lunch is a liar okay
I'd much rather a Big Mac and fries and
a coke then nuggets an apple slices and
Diet Coke give me a break
but I'd also much rather have dinner
okay so basically this lets you make the
trade-off by imposing a budget
constraint by setting relative prices
across goods the points are like noodles
they're not meaningful they're only
meaningful relatively let's you said
relative price across goods and then it
lets you essentially optimize across
those various across those various goods
so budget constraints essentially by
setting up this marginal rate of
transformation help can help with a lot
of kind of decisions in life okay
questions about that okay now what
happens if we shock the budget
constraint so we talked about
constructing them what about shocking
the budget constraint we're gonna do a
lot in this class what we call
comparative statics which is essentially
making changes in one thing or another
and seeing what it does to the system so
let's talk about shocking the budget
constraint let's start first with a
change in prices suppose the price of
pizza goes from 12 dollars up to 18
dollars this is a really good slice of
pizza okay well what happens to the
budget constraint let's look at figure
three to figure three two shows what
happens your regional budgets for NBC
one
the equation of that line is 12 people 6
equals 72 ok the price of pizza dough
number slice of pizza plus the price of
cookies times the number of cookies
equals 72 now the price of pizzas gone
up what that's done is that has pivoted
inward your budget strength to be C 2 it
is flattened the budget constraint
because the slope remembers the ratio of
the price of cookies to the price of
pizza right that's a ratio
well that ratio is just fallen it used
to be a half now it's 1/3 negative 1/2
do all used to be 1/2 now it's 1/3 so
slope has fallen from negative 1/2 to
negative 1/3 so what's happened is you
can still have as many cookies as you
had before the y-intercept has not
changed but you can have fewer slices of
pizza that's why it's a pivot because
one price has not changed only the other
price so it's a pivot inward the other
thing here you'll notice we have all
these funny dots and stuff ok that
represents what has happened to what we
call your opportunity set your
opportunity set which is an important
concept ok your opportunity set is the
set of choices available to you given
your income and market prices the set of
choices available to you given your
income and market prices so your
opportunity set initially was the black
dots plus the red dots now your
opportunity set has shrunk your
opportunity set is now just the black
dots given your income you can now get
less stuff same amount of cookies but
less pizza and you are worse off your
opportunity set has shrunk okay your
opportunity even though your parents
still send me the same check you are
worse off because you can now buy for
less pizza with it ok so that's that's
what happens the opportunity set when a
price changed and likewise should show
to yourself the same thing will happen
when the price of cookies change and
that
you'll get an increase in the steepness
of the budget constraint okay but your
opportunity set will still your
opportunity set will still shrink okay
now what about yeah well that's a good
point we're gonna come back to that we
haven't we assume they're spending all
their money but it's just a way of
representing you can think of the line
being lower it's the same thing
so the Rappard we care about we just
care about the area because it
represents the set but you're right you
could just focus on the line and say the
line is everywhere lower so they're
they're worse off that's another way to
look at it but we like to think about it
as a set it comes in handy for later for
various reasons okay it's a good
question now let's ask about a second
thing what if your income goes up what
if prices are back to twelve and six but
your parents decide to send you more
money
suppose your parents or set thank you
less money turns out you haven't been
paying enough attention to 14:01 your
parents are mad they're monitoring you
that's why we have the camera here this
goes directly to all your parents okay
I'm sort of joking and and so let's say
your parents cut your allowance to $60
okay well what does that do that's in
figure 3 3 okay in figure 3 3 the old
budget constraint was that you get
pizzas and cookies at prices 6 and 12
and you get them to spend $72 now you
can only get them to you spend $60 now
what we see is not a pivot in the budget
constraint but an inward shift in the
budget constraint because the relative
price of pizza cookies has not changed
therefore the slope hasn't changed
okay the slope is dictated solely you
don't do anything to control the slope
the market controls the slope okay but
you and your family control the level
okay and the level has shrunk so you're
pivoting inwards okay and once again now
instead of being able to buy say 12
cookies and six pizzas now you can only
buy say 10 cookies and five pizzas
that's the most you can get okay so once
again your opportunity stat has been
restricted but in a different kind of
way do this pivot inward
so that's how we sort of manipulate
these budget constraints so we're going
to come back to that next lecture
that'll be important
yeah is it more showing that like the
change of slopes doesn't really invite
you to the state by more cookies and
pizza boiling in terms of accurate
budget as a whole decreases and it
affects you overall that's a great
question and we're gonna actually answer
that question next election very
explicitly so hold on to that question
and we'll talk about we're gonna compare
explicitly why income changes differ
from price changes and what are the
underlying mechanisms yeah
great great question so as I said we
always are going to start with
simplifying it some just to make life
easy there's no reason that this
couldn't be written in three dimensions
and you'd have relative marginal rates
of transformation and rates of which
you're willing to trade off various
things so you could just extend the math
from all dimensions it wouldn't add any
richness and just make your head spin so
but the base so the basic all the basic
ideas can come across with two goods but
it would be the same mechanics with more
goods okay you essentially when we get
to the constrained optimization you
essentially have more first-order
conditions in your constrained
optimization it's the way to think about
it
okay so let's access a great segue let's
turn to the second part which is how we
use budget constraints and the utility
function we learned out last time to
actually decide describe how consumers
make choices so we take utility remember
I said last time consumers are going to
maximize the utility subject your
buckets budget constraint well now we've
taught you about utility we've taught
you about budget constraints let's put
them together okay how to consume how do
consumers put them together well
graphically the representation of
preferences was our indifference curves
that represented people's indifference
with further indifference curves made
people happy right that was last time so
a sense who organized graphically is
what is the highest indifference curve
you can achieve given your budget right
we know you want be the highest
indifference curve possible buy mores
better so we're simply going to ask what
is the highest indifference curve you
can reach given your budget okay
so let's consider the same utility from
last time utility is square root of P
times C okay
and let's consider the same budget we
wrote down up here $72 income $12 price
of Pizza $6 price of cookies and now
let's ask where can you go with that so
let's sort of figure three four and do
it graphically we'll do it
mathematically in a minute okay so in
figure three four you have our budget
constraint which runs from six pizzas to
twelve cookies that
the original budget constraint and you
have a series of indifference curves and
these indifference curves i1 i2 i3 i-4
they all come directly from this utility
function
so simply I've solved this utility
function I'll start to talk about the
math in a little bit you'll do more math
and section on Friday okay but
essentially you can solve we will show
you you'll derive on Friday how you take
this utility function literally can draw
the indifference curves from it okay but
for now take my word that these
indifference curves represent this
utility function and what we see is that
point D is the farthest out indifference
curve you can achieve while still
meeting your budget while saving your
budget constraint and therefore we say
that the optimum graphically is the
tangency between your indifference curve
and your budget constraint is the
optimal constrained bundle you see we
brought last time we talked about
further indifference curves make you
happier this today we talked about the
fact you are limited by your budget so
we have the furthest indifference curve
you can get to is going to be
definitionally at the tangent of the
indifference curve in the budget
constraint and once again that gives you
we realize we don't want to measure
utils but just for mathematical for Rep
methanol voters that gives utility at
that tangency of square root of 18 okay
at that point you are choosing six
cookies and three pizzas that is the
choice you are making that is the best
off you can get given your budget and to
see this let's talk about some other
points and why they're not better okay
let's talk about point a why is it point
a about it why isn't it better to have
two maybe just maybe you like cookies a
lot and don't let it would like pizza on
all the cookies that much how can we say
that point D is better than point a yeah
it's not a higher indifference curve so
Point D dominates point a because a
higher indifference curve well find the
same person by that logic why not choose
point E
yeah you can't afford it so the bottom
line is you can see graphically why the
tangency is the best your going is the
best you're going to to do okay
likewise points II wouldn't choose Point
C is has this has the same slope it has
the same slope as Point D in other words
the slopes minus 1/2 at Point C you've
drew a line tangent to Point C the slope
will be minus 1/2 just like it is a
point D but you wouldn't be spending all
your money so you wouldn't choose that
point either yeah we're we're gonna
we're gonna come to it we got well I
just first of all we're not gonna have
discrete and if it well we can have
lines and the lines could end up you
could end up lying along and then you
could and then applying along a budget
constraint for example or you could have
you could even have utility functions
which judge your budget rating at one
extreme or another and we'll talk about
those cases yeah yeah well let's come to
the math then ok let's come to the
mathematical derivation so that's the
graphics let's come to the math okay now
always a bit of a tightrope act when I'm
doing math up here on the board so bear
with me okay but the key thing is the
math of constraint optimization is all
about the marginal decision
remember it's hard to say how many
cookies you want it's easier to say
should I have the next cookie okay it's
about constraint optimization and what
we want to ask is we essentially want to
compare how do you feel about trading
off pizzas versus cookies versus what
will the market let you do instead of
trading off pieces versus cookies that
is we the Optoma is going to occur when
we set your marginal rate of
substitution which remember we defined
is minus mu c over mu P equal I'm going
to get rid of this equal to ah
your marginal rate of transformation
which we defined as - PC over PEP and
this is the fundamental equation of
consumer choice if you understand this
equation you can solve virtually every
consumer choice problem we'll give you
okay
that basically at the optimum the ratio
of margin utilities equals the ratio of
prices prices that is the rate at which
you want to trade off Pizza for cookies
is the rate at which the market will
allow you to trade off Pizza for cookies
okay
basically it's saying the ratio of the
benefits think of this as the benefits
and this is the cost think of the mrs as
the benefits it's what you want MRT is
the cost it's where your constraint you
want set the ratio of the benefits equal
to the ratio of the costs okay now I
find it actually easier to think of it
this way if you just rearrange terms you
can write it as mu C over PC equals mu P
over P sub P I like this way of writing
it because I I call this the bang for
the buck equation what this is saying
your marginal happiness per dollar
should be equal this is sort of the
happiness per dollar spent on cookies
this is the happiness per dollar spent
on pizza and you want those to be equal
if you want the bang for the put your
next dollar where it's gonna make you
happiest okay
and so basically think of that as your
bang for your buck so for example
suppose you were in a position where the
mrs was greater than the mrt you're in a
position where the marginal utility of
cookies and I'm getting rid the
negatives there's negative on both sides
I'm just gonna get rid of the negatives
okay
the Marrs utility of cookies over the
Marg utility of pizza was greater than
the price of cookies over the price of
pizza okay that is the slope of the
indifference curve was greater than the
slope of the budget constraint this is a
slope of the indifference curve
okay so I'll be your scribe this is the
slope of the budget constraint in
absolute value the slope of the
indifference curve is greater an
absolute value than the slope of the
budget constraint okay that'd be true at
points like point a point a where you
intersect where you basically except
from above the the budget rent by the
indifference curve so a point like a
point a has a steeper slope of the
indifference curves than does the budget
constraint what that says is intuitively
and once again I want you to see any
intuition the rate at which you are
willing to give up the rate at which you
are willing to give up cookies for
pizzas I'm sorry let me say that let me
say in a better way the marginal benefit
to you of another cookie relative to
another pizza is higher than what the
market will charge you to turn pizza
into cookies let me say it again the
marginal benefit to you of another
cookie which is this this how much more
you want the next cookie relative how
much more you want the next pizza it's
greater than what the markets gonna
charge you to trade in your pizza for
cookies
therefore you should trade in your pizza
for cookies okay so let's see this
mathematically at a point like a point a
okay you have your margin utility for
pizza is the derivative of the utility
function with respect to the number of
slices of pizza it's marginal utilities
the river the utility function so it's D
u DP okay which is equal to 0.5 times C
over square root of P times C okay so
and at Point a at Point a we had we had
two cookies and five pizzas at Point a P
was five C was - okay that's true point
a so we can evaluate this Marg utility
UDP which equals zero point five times C
over square root of P times C so that's
1 over the square root of 10 okay
that's a margin utility of the next
slice of pizza the next slice the
Pichichi makes you one over square root
of ten happy once again that numbers
meaningless we only care about in ratios
so we need the ratio so let's do the
Mars utility of cookies that's D you DC
which is 0.5 times P over square root of
P times C which is 2.5 over the square
root of 10 okay so the Mars utility of
Pizza is 1 over square root of 10 large
utility of cookies is 2.5 or the square
root of 10 therefore your marginal rate
of substitution is minus 2.5 remember
marginal rate of substitution is mu C
over mu P so your modulated
substitutions minus 2.5 what does that
mean
can anyone tell me what that means your
margin rate of substitution is 2.5 what
is that that is a meaningful concept
noodles are not but that is yeah say
you'll at least within here you will
exactly or willing to give up 2.5 slices
of pizza for one cookie that's what that
number means and that is a meaningful
number that's not an order that's
cardinal we can use that you are willing
to give up 2.5 slices of pizza to get
one cookie
what is the market asking you to give up
how much pizza do you have to give up to
get one cookie half a slice you are
happy to give up two and a half slices
of pizza to get a cookie but the markets
saying we'll let you have a cookie for
half a slice of pizza so what should you
do eat less Petey more cookies that will
unambiguously make you happier and
that's why you should move from point A
towards point D okay that's the
intuition okay you basically want to
trade pizza for cookies until these
things are equal indeed I would like you
to go home and do the same math starting
at point B if you the main same math
start at point B you'll find the MRF
is much below 1/2 that is at that point
you're happy to give up tons of cookies
to get pizza because geez you got 10
cookies at one slice of pizza you give
up tons of cookies to get pizza but the
market says you only have to get 2
cookies to get pizza
so you'll happily do it and you move
back towards point D and that's the sort
of in a bundle sort of the intuition in
math and graphics of how we do
constrained optimization okay that is
hard and very important questions about
that don't hesitate to ask okay
that is hard and very important if you
understand this you're sort of done with
consumer theory okay this is sort of the
core of what consumer theory is all
about it's all about this balancing act
the whole course is fundamentally all
about one equation which is marginal
benefits equals marginal costs okay
everything we do is going about weighing
the marginal benefit of an activity
against its marginal costs the if we
take the next step what's the benefit
what's the cost well here the marginal
benefit CMRS the marginal cost the MRT
we want to set them equal and this sort
of example I hope explained why ok so
that is how we think about good strange
choice now want to apply it I don't
apply it by looking at the example of
food stamps ok
now food stamps are not actually called
food stamps anymore when I was a kid
they're called food stamps it's
basically a program the government has
that provides money for individuals to
buy food if they're low-income
essentially we have in the u.s. what's
called the poverty line and I'll talk a
lot more about this at the end of the
class but the poverty line says she's a
measure of what's a minimum level of
resources you need to live in America
the poverty line for an individual is
about $14,000 ok for a family of four
it's about $28,000 I feel that number
obvious can depend on where you're from
if you're in Boston will say that's
insane if for some real part of the
country you think yeah that's poor but
manageable ok we'll talk later about the
poverty line what's good and bad about
it but in any case if you're below the
poverty line in America roughly speaking
you get help with buying food
and that comes the program we now call
snap used to be called food stamps I got
update my notes supplemental nutrition
and I don't know I know the answer for
nutrition okay so basically what the
snap program does is it gives you a
debit card if you qualifying income
grounds you get a debit card and that
debit card can be used to buy food and
food only okay so essentially a debit
card from the government that you can
use to buy food if you're poor enough
and they give you sort of a fixed amount
every month and that month could be used
to purchase food so here's the question
why Co through this rigmarole why not
just give people cash well this fancy
thing one if we want to give poor people
money much give money and we're gonna I
don't want the answer yet okay what I
want to do is show you graphically how
we think about the trade-off and then
we'll come to the answer so hold your
thoughts
so let's actually graph how we think
about food stamps let's go to figure
three five a and let's start with a cash
transfer so here's the setup imagine
people start with an income of $5,000
that's super poor okay five thousand
dollars a whole family income for the
year okay and let's say all they can
spend it on is food or shelter remember
us this gentleman pointed out in life
there's more than two goods but it makes
a lot easier to have two goods so
imagine in this case you're two goods
are food and shelter and actually quite
frankly you're that poor that probably
is only two goods you have to well you
can worry about at that level of income
okay it's food and shelter see if five
thousand dollars to vote to food and
shelter so you have some original budget
line okay which is labeled their
original budget line that runs from five
thousand and food to five thousand
shelter and then you can have some of
in-between some some of some along the
way okay now let's say we give someone
five or drawls in cash obviously this
graph is not to scale okay it looks like
you're doubling as income is only five
hundred dollars just this just sort of
makes it easier not to scale graph let's
say we give someone we say to them look
you're poor we're gonna give you five
hundred bucks in cash well now all we've
done is shift out your budget constraint
from five thousand fifty five hundred
okay we've shifted out your budget
training for five thousand and fifty
five hundred
what is that due to your choices well
consider two different types of people
person why okay they used to be on
different skirt eyes ear oh they used to
spend almost all their income on food
and not allowed on shelter they're
probably homeless okay
so they spend all their money on food
and we're basically homeless now what do
they do well they spend a little more on
food and a lot more on shelter maybe now
they get you know foreign Joss doesn't
buy you much shelter they spend a little
more okay maybe if maybe a night a week
they can get shelter okay so basically
that's what they do that's their
constrained optimization we're not
saying it's right or wrong this is not
normative economics it's positive the
positive thing is given their utility
function they move from point y1 to y2
now imagine someone like individual X
they're different their tastes are such
that they don't need to eat they just
want to have shelter so they're up at
point x1 initially and you even that
$500 and they spend just a little bit
more of it than food and even more of it
on shelter they just love their shelter
okay and they're just super
they're super weight watchers they don't
eat okay so basically they move from x1
x2 once again not normative right or
wrong it's just these are feasible
choices people could make given the
opportunity set with which they're faced
and that's absolutely the $500 in cash
question about what I did here on this
graph alone yeah okay that's a good
point we'll come back to that that's
time out if you're not a sports fan okay
so we will we will we will come back to
that and in fact um okay but but do
people understand what the cash transfer
is how it works okay now let's go to
snap and let's say with snap instead of
giving them 500 hours to get in the
debit card instead of hanging them 500
AutoCheck we give them a debit card with
500 hours on it that can only be used on
food how does this affect their budget
constraint now we see where budget
renditions start to get interesting and
fun and the kind of challenges you're
going to face in this course in drawing
budget constraints the original budget
constraint continues to be the original
budget line running for five thousand
five thousand the new budget constraint
is this kinked line
that runs from 5,000 the y-axis to the
point x2 okay at 5,000 y-axis so it
starts at 5,000 y-axis 0 on the x-axis
there's a flat line that goes to 5000 on
Y axis 500 on the x-axis and then it
slopes down parallel to the original
budget constraint to 5500 can someone
explain to me why that's the new budget
constraint yeah exactly we are forcing
you to spend at least $500 compared to
cash we can do whatever the hell you
want we are forcing you to spend $500 of
your money on food come into the
question back there
it doesn't have to be a specific label
500 could be any 500 but we're forcing
you to spend at least 500 dollars on
food well what does that do to your
choices well for person Y it makes no
difference whether they get cash or
whether they get food stamps now the
person like blue shirt turquoise shirt
or ask that question why does it make no
difference yeah why does it with
whatever greenish I'm no waste yeah you
what why does it make no difference for
person Y it's like in food stamps or
cash
exactly he could just reallocate his
money okay
that's exactly right so foreperson why
there's no difference look they're
already spending what forty nine hundred
bucks on food you give him a thing
labeled five dollars for food it's not
going to affect their life they'll just
take five hundred they'll just Spence
they'll just treat his 500 more in cash
they're indifferent so nothing affects
them but what about person X well person
X remember the dashed portion of this
budget constraint is from the old cash
example and the dotted indifference
curve is what they would have chosen
with cash
remember person X with cash what ifs
chosen to still spend less than five
hundred dollars on food even when you
gave them five hundred dollars they
still only spent $300 on food so we are
forcing them to not be on their
preferred budget constraint rather we're
forcing them down to point X 2 which is
they'll spend you know the minimum they
can on food to the minimum is $500 okay
they are forcing them down to point X 2
now why do I say forcing them why do I
know for sure they are being forced that
they're less happy at X 2 than they
would have been when they get in the
cash I don't know that for sure yeah
exactly think of it this way the
fundamental thing is people always get
to the point that makes them happiest
okay we call the robustness of economic
equilibria people get to what makes and
happiest they want they always before
had the choice of any 500 food and they
chose not to therefore if you forced a
9,500 food they must be less happy ok
think of it that way
they always could have spent $5.00 on
food they didn't there's where I forced
them you're making them less happy ok so
they are worse off okay they are forced
to spend they'd rather spend some of
that money finding nicer place to live
but we're not letting them we're making
them buy food ok do people I don't want
I just want to be understand that the
graphics here and the collusions I drew
ok
now why why are we doing this why would
you they're better off with cash why
would we force them to have food yeah
okay but basically what you're saying is
you know better than the guy if let me
let me say I'm not accusing you I'm just
saying look if if people knew best maybe
they'd like to just like have a nice
house and die okay if people knew best
then there'd be no reason to do this the
reason to do this is because we think
they don't know best so for example
let's change the label on the y-axis
just a small change let's cross our
shelter and write cocaine okay
well in that case maybe we don't feel so
bad by forcing the guy to buy food
instead of cocaine okay in other words
this is a program which might make sense
if we are paternalistic now we're
getting into norm of economics
paternalistic if we think that people
will initially make the right decisions
for themselves then it may be worth
actually making them worse off because
they're not worse off they're their
perceived benefits are worse but they
don't know what they're doing okay
now you can see why I hope you can sort
of immediately see why this concept
makes economists a little nervous
because why don't we know what they want
better than they do okay so it makes
people a little bit nerdy kinds a little
bit nervous a lot of people a little bit
nervous to say gee maybe they're just
happy you're doing cocaine and how do we
know that that's the wrong way for them
to spend the resources yeah
that's a very good point now but there's
sort of two points there first of all if
the taxpayers goal is to help poor
people then why shouldn't you make them
as happy as possible right if they tax
why am i giving money this poor guy
because I'm sad he's poor but what
you're saying I'm not actually that sad
he's poor I'm sad he's not eating if
you're really just sad he's poor they
should give him money if what you're sad
about is gee I don't like how he's
living I don't like this I'm sad he can
have better food eat excited Felice
didn't live then you're starting to
impose your preferences but let's be
important that's imposing your
preferences yeah well that's that's a
related point of the taxpayer if the
taxpayer cares about look we want
healthy populace that's going to live a
long time and be productive and pay
taxes then that would be a reason to do
this but once again I want to emphasize
okay this is paternalism if you really
just care what makes people happy it's
you should give them cash okay so that
raises two questions okay um first of
all uh first question yeah
yeah yeah so basically it's a great
question in general we're gonna I'm
gonna answer a lot of those questions
with the same cheat this semester which
is we're going to assume the markets are
perfectly functioning so there's no
you're imposing sort of a market failure
if there's no market once there's market
failures all bets are off but with no
market failure and no paternalism you'd
want to give them cash this raises an
important question do food stamps
actually increase food purchases first
of all there's two reasons why that
might not reason one is everybody could
be like why ok X is sort of silly case
right you're gonna die if you eat that
little and food stamps aren't that much
they're you know maybe like three grand
a year that reason is ten three grand on
food so the first issue is you know the
first reason why food stamps may not
matter is that in fact everybody's
spending at least a dime a degrees like
why nobody's like X what's another
reason why it might not matter what's a
REIT what's a way people could get
around food stamps yeah yeah they could
set up a black market where they
essentially say look I only want two
thousand dollars of food the guards
making worth three thousand I'll buy my
extra thousand dollars of food I'll sell
the people who do want it and I'll end
up still leaving two thousand dollars
worth of food so we actually want to
know do food stamps actually increase
food consumption in practice are they
making a difference well actually we've
run an experiment on this okay we're
gonna talk in this class a lot about
empirical results in economics we'll
talk where this class is mostly going to
be a theoretical class that is we talk
about models and ideas but we're also
since basically I'm an empirical
economists we're going to talk about
about empirical economics which is
results and testing the theories we
develop empirically now here's a great
example in our mixes we set up a
theoretical model you always want to
start with the theory but the theory
sometimes has predictions which are
uncertain here we have an uncertain
prediction from theory about whether
food stamps will affect food purchase or
not so let's test it and the way we test
it is we actually have run that food
stamps cash out experiments where we
literally take
food stamps that give them cash instead
and watch what happens to their
consumption before and after it's a real
randomized trial we literally flip a
coin head you keep your food stamped
tails we replace those food stamps with
an equal amount of cash then watch what
happens what happens is that people
spend about 15% less on food when you
give them cash instead of food stamps
that is food stamps is forcing people to
spend about 15% more on food than they
would like to unconstraint by the cash
yeah
yeah you know it's a great question and
that's there's you're asking about
richer theory richer theory and I'm
telling you that I'm gonna give you the
empirical evidence or whatever the
theory is the empirical evidence tells
you what happens and you just those
different explanations for why empirical
evidence is that basically the price of
our paternalism is 15% okay we are
making people effectively 15% worse off
making them spend 15% more on food and
they want to so is it worth it well
actually the evidence is starting to
pour in that it might not be worth it
because there's starting to be a lot of
experiments we're giving people just
cash especially developing countries and
developing countries the answer seems to
be just giving people cash makes them
better off that actually especially in
developing countries people use the cash
in productive ways so for example they
have a series of evaluation programs
where they've given people cash most in
developing countries in Africa in
particular some in the US and they find
that people spend relatively little of
that on you know drugs and alcohol but
they actually tend to spend it
productively and in fact they found
developing countries this all provides
valuable resources for individuals to
start businesses sarandon experiment in
Uganda where a non-profit company
randomly offered a group of winner 150
dollars okay which is huge Rolf's our
income that's 50 to 100 percent of
annual income in Uganda fifty one
hundred and fifty dollars and what they
found was after two months after
eighteen months these women had used
that money to start businesses and that
actually raised their earnings that
actually effectively
doubled their earnings from that one in
injection of cash it led them to
actually double their annual earnings
okay
so that leads one to think that maybe we
should stop being paternalistic and just
give cash unfortunately if you're a
reader of policy websites like I am the
best one of which is voxcom it's a great
website they had an article just the
other day pointing out how it so he
followed these women up nine years later
in nine years later the effect had
totally gone away so until you know the
story isn't quite necessarily positive
but it's not negative they're not worse
off but it looks like at least was in
the short run made them better off all
that effect fades over time
but the bottom line is at this point the
evidence is sort of probably in favor of
being less paternalistic in just giving
people cash but that that runs into a
lot of difficulties in terms of our
concerns about how people spend it so
let me stop there we will come back on
Monday and we'll talk about how we
actually go from this stuff to the
demand curves we started the class with